And the answer here is that the weight of the tree is always smaller
than the length of the shortest tour.
And the reason for that is the following: When you have a shortest tour
for a given graph, then you can always transform the shortest tour
into a spanning tree because the shortest tour visits each vertex at least once,
so the connectedness is given.
But, of course, a shortest tour always contains at least 1 cycle
because you have to get back to the vertex where you started from.
So you  have to remove at least 1 edge from the shortest tour in order to make it a spanning tree.
And then you have a spanning tree with a weight that is
definitely less than the length of the shortest tour,
because you have removed at least 1 edge.
And now here, you even have a minimum spanning tree,
so the weight of the minimum spanning tree must be even smaller.
And that is why the weight of the minimum spanning tree
is smaller than the length of the shortest tour.